oh great first impression
hello and welcome to Saturday hurry
the look back at my week I'm grace
Helbig if you don't know this where do
we go from here here's some stuff that
has happened to me all week
you know know-it-all in specific order
of like what it happened but it's not
pieced together very well so take a look
and then surprise is coming along quite
nicely yeah back under stop this is how
we communicate now we've stopped talking
to each other
it's your birthday and we know what you
love more than French mustard
I think that woman has a problem you
guys you guys
Oh back in Los Angeles in my bathroom so
Chalet we're getting ready we're gonna
go to a shoot I'm straightening my hair
before not before after we're gonna go
to a shoot for what's trending right now
for a new series they're doing called
behind the video it's like behind the
music behind the video retro very back
and here's a fun thing that's happening
is that I haven't had my hair extensions
spoiler dead hair extensions updated a
long time so they're just like boo boo
fallen out Oh him but the good thing is
after the shoot Wendy's going over to
fix my hair Wow memory and I do a live
stream for here USA because I don't have
time to do one thing at a time anymore
we're gonna car I forgot what cars are
like spoiler they're like cars
it's got my hair done and sometimes I
guess my hair looks so gross a lot of
the time because I don't maintain it
that when it gets done finally it looks
so nice that I think I'm wearing awake
although I don't know why my standard of
nice hair is wigs
guitar
so glamorous
hello beer home right now I did the talk
this morning which was really fun and so
fast and so furious and every woman
there was so nice I don't think I was
actually present when it was happening
the only thing I kept saying myself this
just smile so you don't look crazy or
uninterested these eyelashes though I'm
about to go to a book signing in a
little bit so I'm going to try and keep
them from falling off my face until then
before the book signing we're going over
to my Marie's house and we are doing a
quick excuse me who know that's over
with
a quick shot I woke up this morning and
it felt really like I'm getting sick I
think I had more than like an hour worth
of time in the past couple of days to
relax and my body was like aha this is
the little schedule being sick so I'm
drinking tea and I was watching Meghan
batoon because I don't know if you guys
know who she is she's this youtuber it's
also a dancer and she's really great I'm
really funny and I'm kind of obsessed
with her sorry Meghan but soon if you
watch this and she has the most amazing
eyebrows I've ever seen in a human being
so I don't really know what most of her
videos about cuz I'm just looking I did
my brows dance
coca-cola and Kenya Moore's head is a
quarter coke
morning we're going to the book signing
at the Barnes & Noble in the gallery
yeah yeah yeah look out sating look how
exciting
look how exciting look how exciting oh
my god that book is turn
we're back in New York we were headed to
a cosmopolitan event called the fun -
fearless life event I am a attending the
kind of sick side retired life event so
far so good we are back from the
cosmopolitan fun fearless life event
it's always very cool and very
intimidating being in events like that I
didn't take any video there one because
my throat sounds like this - because all
but it's all like really powerful
executives and we might be like part of
me CEO of Twitter no he would have
understood he was really great I got to
be on a panel with dick Oh what is this
last name likey now a Twitter guy
Twitter guys how I professionally label
everyone and he is very cool he's really
really cool smart dude so it makes me
like Twitter that much more but the best
part of the whole event is that they
give you a gift bag for being there so I
haven't opened it yet go through the
give back and they give you this what
the what is this ultimate you eat
Ultimate Ears I think it's a speaker I
thought it was like a bottle of
something but it I think it's a speaker
that looks like an energy drink ooh a
wallet what is it though and charge your
smartphone on the go
no I had this idea I'll Express tech
portable smartphone charger god damn it
I had this idea it's a little cute
wallet and I'm sure inside there are
things to charge your phone with on the
go but also this is really cute and I
will use this so I'll open that later
HMS camera oh I'm color tattoo ha in a
color that I don't have I'm actually
wearing some right now in the brown
shade Oh
what how opened oh my gosh what is what
is it
Oh what what are you it's a necklace
with a thing that's got stuff in it
that's it that's so cute oh I love gift
baskets I love just free stuff in
general okay I'm gonna go um kill myself
a little bit before going to another
event tonight please if you haven't
already the full episodes of memory next
travel show hey USA is up but hey let's
say got the scene calm that's really
exciting mamrie and I are going on the
road doing some live shows please buy
your tickets they're almost sold out
we're so excited to be going to the
cities that we're going to because they
have not been visited by us before in
the live show since links are down below
and I don't know
Sam holes in my back cool with that
tooth I know I self-conscious about it
so until the Dodgers was it they're not
they're not real they fade away none of
this is making it